une importante nouvelle médical qui est
passée inaperçue car la journée même de
son annonce et l attentat au charlie
hebdo le 7 janvier dernier on a annoncé
la découverte d'une nouvelle classe
d'antibiotiques
une annonce importante puisque depuis
trente ans la recherche biomédicale et
pharmaceutiques n'avait produit aucun
nouvel antibiotique ce qui a accentué la
résistance des pathogènes aux
antibiotiques existants mont saint
michel
c'est donc une découverte qui suscite de
l'espoir de mieux contrôler les
bactéries absolument et c'est un espoir
qui était nécessaire
ces découvertes cet effet par une équipe
de l'université northeastern à boston
publiée dans nature est grosso modo ils
ont découvert en fait toute une classe
25 antibiotiques différents dont un est
très prometteur car comment est ce
qu'ils ont fait pour en découvrir 25
d'un coup agents n'avaient pas attraper
enfin ils ont été très ingénieux et 13
astuces ont posé une seule question où
est ce qu'on pourrait trouver 10
milliards de bactéries la réponse est
dans le sol mais dans le sol on sait que
seulement 1% de ces bactéries là on peut
les reproduire et les cultive en
laboratoire alors ils sont aussi bons
mais regardons prenons laboratoire est
dense et mettons le littéralement dans
le sol car comment est ce qu'ils ont
fait ça regardez c'est tout simple ils
ont tout simplement pris des plaques en
fait qu'ils sont pas plus grosses que ça
qu'à l'intérieur de chaque plat qu'il ya
de petites alvéoles et dans ses alliés
l'ont même bactérie pathogène
on l'a fait cultiver on ferme le tout et
on met ça dans le sol on laisse à
plusieurs jours
on sort on regarde en laboratoire et on
trouve que les pathogènes ont
effectivement eu des molécules sont en
train l'intérieur qui lisons détruites
hélas ces molécules à ce sont en fait
les antibiotiques
il ya là 25 mai il y en a un qui
particulièrement prometteur alors là
texto bakhtine s'attaque à deux maladies
la tuberculose dont la résistance
commence à augmenter c'est très
inquiétant et le sarm dont le
staphylocoque doré résistant à la
vancomycine qu'on retrouve dans les
hôpitaux uniquement pour l'instant à
quelle somme alesi nosocomiales mais qui
risquent peut-être un jour d'aller à la
communauté donc il faut rapidement
commencé des études cliniques avec cette
nouvelle molécule
évidemment si on parle de ça aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il faut rappeler michel à quel
point les antibiotiques sont importants
oui c'est possiblement une des plus
grandes
découverte de l'histoire de la médecine
ça commence en 1928 avec la pénicilline
d'ailleurs fleming qui avait découvert
cette molécule abedi vingt ans plus tard
en recevant son prix nobel
il faut absolument être ouvert au fait
qu'un jour nos bactéries sont
résistantes à la pénicilline il avait
raison par la suite on a fait d'autres
découvertes une dizaine de classes
d'antibiotiques mais depuis 1987 silence
radio plus rien de plus les médecins ont
su utiliser ces molécules hla les
patients n'ont pas pris leur posologie
comme il faut quant on titille jours ces
dix jours six et huit jours on est deux
jours là avec des bactéries résistantes
qui est qui qui se multiplient donc je
crois qu'il ya un cri d'alarmé
j'espère que ces nouvelles molécules là
vont permettre d'ici quelques années
d'avoir deux ou trois bons aux
antibiotiques chez le pharmacien
c'est ce qu'on se souhaite oui merci
beaucoup merci